president Trump's torrent of cough fa
has washed away squishy Republicans bob
Corker and Jeff Flake and the Trump is
not a conservative narrative takes
another hit then Hollywood culture and
blogging icon Perez Hilton offers the
inside scoop on la-la lands downfall
finally Allie Stuckey Ariel Davidson and
Emily Butler joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss an actress so
desperate for attention that she accused
93 year-old wheelchair-bound former
President George Bush of sexual assault
just for touching her took us the latest
details in Democrats collusion with
Russia and the Las Vegas shooters
pedophile brother
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a great show we've got today we are
going to bring on the og blogger himself
Perez Hilton in a second but first we
can't get to that yet because we have
some good news we have a sponsor someone
is going to keep the lights on here this
one is helix sleep they're gonna allow
us to bring you cool guys like Perez
Hilton and tell all these all of these
news stories and analyze all of the
coffe effe helix sleep is really good I
feel like these have all been just
falling out of heaven
these are all very providential sponsors
because if you've ever shopped for a
mattress you know it's like the worst
experience on the face of the earth it's
one it's hard to find one that you like
you can never find one that's really
custom-built to you it's very expensive
you got to go around to all these places
going into matrix stores it's not my
idea of a good time probably it isn't
yours either
so guess what one size fits all does not
work in mattresses helix sleep offers
something that does not exist anywhere
else there's no other company doing this
it's a mattress personalized to your
unique preferences and sleeping style
that won't set you back thousands of
dollars you can get a personalized
mattress but you're gonna have to take
out a second mortgage on your house
usually this is not the case helix is
really good at this
I go to helix sleep comm slash no excuse
me slash Knowles
that's KN o wles you just go to helix
sleep comm slash Knowles take their two
to three minutes sleep quiz they will
build you a custom mattress that will be
the best thing that you have ever slept
on now for couples this is this is
really good I'm gonna have to ask sweet
little Elise about this
they personalize each side of the
mattress so I like a firmer mattress
sweet little Lisa likes it to be like
feathers floating on a cloud and helix
sleep will make one that fits you both
you know everyone's talking about it
from GQ to Cosmopolitan New York Times
they're all talking about helix once you
try it you will know why but now this is
the part I really like their custom
mattress is just delivered to you
completely free there's no shipping
there's also no risk so if you go on
there you'll get a mattress custom-made
just for you just for you and your
partner and then they'll deliver it for
free you get to try it risk-free
a hundred days if you don't like it then
you can just return it and there's no
questions asked no you don't need to
explain why you could feel the pee
underneath your mattress you know or the
little carrot or something you just it's
just if it's not perfect for you then
you can just send it right back so go to
helix sleep calm slash Knowles KN o WL
es right now you'll get fifty dollars
toward your custom mattress that's helix
sleep comm slash Knowles KN o WL es just
like my cousin Beyonce fifty dollars off
your custom mattress there's absolutely
no risk whatsoever no shipping charges
plus you can check out their mattress
protector maybe you check out their
helix foundation I don't know go there
right now you you won't regret that you
did and and try it out okay thank you to
Hilux now we got to bring on Perez
Hilton Perez man thank you so much for
being here happy so for those of you and
unfortunately I can't hear Perez right
now so hopefully in the control room
they'll figure that out Perez Hilton is
the most prominent blogger in Hollywood
history yeah he doesn't need an
introduction but give him one anyway he
really he was one of the first bloggers
period certainly the biggest one out
here in la-la land now Hollywood is
crumbling groped by grope and we are
lucky to have the number one expert on
behind the scenes machinations Perez my
first question is this the end for
Hollywood I definitely don't think that
everything that's happened as the result
of this Harvey Weinstein scandal will
very negatively impact Hollywood you
know Hollywood is a very forgiving town
I don't think that he will be able to
have a comeback what I do think will
happen as a result of this is we as a
world and a community here in Los
Angeles are now creating a culture where
we're letting women know that it is okay
for them to speak out that they will be
supportive that they will be heard
understood and believed do you think
though I mean ice it's obviously people
are pouring out there's this bandwagon
now that Harvey Weinstein has been
exposed formerly the biggest guy in town
now he's being run out on a rail but is
it just
is it just the bandwagon I mean I
noticed people aren't naming a whole lot
of other names right now does that
culture where you're afraid of of saying
the wrong thing about the powerful
people does that still persist does this
it's not even a casting couch it's my
like way sleazier than a casting couch
is that is this just we kicked a guy
while he was already falling out of
power or is the culture of Hollywood
actually changing well I pay very close
attention to everything happening and I
I see the opposite happening I've seen
over the last couple of weeks many other
women and men come forward sharing their
very personal stories about similar
experiences you know there was this very
well-known oscar-nominated director who
recently over a hundred and ninety women
came forward and said he did all of
these inappropriate things to me
there was a Hollywood talent agent a man
who was very inappropriate towards his
male client and others in that world and
it's a smaller scale things like this
has have been happening as well not just
in Hollywood but in other industries as
well I don't think this is a problem
that is exclusive to show business they
might not be exclusion it's certainly
amplified even just because we're all
watching it you know I mean we see this
is an industry where the the currency of
the industry are people you know when
you when you cast or when you audition
for a role the product is you so
obviously there's a natural intimacy
where lines can be blurred but you do
you I mean you pay as much attention to
this place as anybody probably much more
is there another shoe that's gonna drop
or there other big players that are
gonna fall other big institutions like
The Weinstein Company is this the is
this the end of this scandal or is it
only the beginning um I definitely don't
think it's the end of this scandal I
think that there will continue to be
developments along the way I mean just
today there were a report that the
weinstein company may have to file for
bankruptcy
see reports which I should add they are
denying but there have been reports and
accusations against Harvey Weinstein's
brother the Harvey specific story is one
that won't be going away anytime soon
and the repercussions of that throughout
show business I think will be continued
to be felt for quite some time and you
know I actually give you some credit for
all of this obviously it's a you know
you started doing this to over ten years
ago and you were the first big blogger
and certainly the first big Hollywood
blogger but you really shone a light in
a way that other tabloids didn't really
do I mean you brought this kind of
Hollywood scrutiny and microscope into
the internet age and obviously there's a
lot of entertainment that goes along
with that as well
do you take any any of the credit or any
of the responsibility for ripping open
the veil that covered Hollywood for so
long not at all I would get credit first
and foremost to Ashley jar she was the
first major player to speak on the
record to be fearless enough to put
herself her reputation and her career on
the line in speaking to the New York
Times because they had difficulty
getting countless women to speak on the
record and she did and she really let
other women know it's okay to share your
story it's funny you and I obviously
probably have different political views
but when you look we on the right we
conservatives we always like to make fun
of crazy Hollywood actors and actresses
saying wild political activist
statements but then when you when you
look at what some of these people have
gone through in their professional lives
a lot of them since they were children
you get a little bit more empathy I
think and you say you know this is a
pretty weird town and weird profession
and if it if it changes your mind and
warps your vision of things you know
there but for the grace of God go I
possibly Ashley Judd is an example
because we all of we conservatives made
fun of her political statements for the
last two years my last question for you
what's the next shoe to drop what is the
next where is this going
both the industry and the and obviously
this particular issue of the sexual
harassment and sexual assault I think
that
it remains to be seen I actually am a
little bit pessimistic I don't know
how much of a change it will have just
because by nature there are bad people
in this world man I do believe that this
will continue to happen just because
there are those that get a taste of
power and let it get to their head and
they will abuse those underneath them I
mean one of the other stories about
Harvey Weinstein that also resonated to
me wasn't that I said in addition to him
sexually harassing all these women
according to them was that according to
other women he was such a bully that he
would bully actresses allegedly to where
his wife Georgina Chapman is close she's
a fashion designer you know there will
always be those bullies there will
always be those higher up they treat
people beneath them awfully in show
business in politics across the board
well politics is just show business for
ugly people as you know you're right
about the bullying and you see it with a
you know a lot of my friends who are
working at production houses or working
for a big agency or whatever the stories
you hear of like phones being thrown
across the room and having to work 20
hours straight engine it is really
vicious and even more so than I think
I've heard from my friends in other
high-pressure fields like finance or
maybe politics is the only analog is it
the is it the narcissism is it the
vanity that comes along with show
business and politics that makes these
egos turn so monstrous no I think it's
the fact that for so long so many people
could get away with so much so much was
overlooked so much was accepted oh they
just do that that's been going on like
that forever whereas a more corporate
environment the more traditional
workplace would not accept and tolerate
behavior that is accepted and tolerated
in show business for politics there is a
permissiveness that's true you wouldn't
get it in a lot of other industries
where people are a little more grounded
in I make a widget and I sell a widget
and then people buy a widget
this we're here you're you know creating
the inner life of characters you're
casting people to go from nothing to
have the heights of glamour and fame and
power that is really corrupting and it's
it's hard to keep a rein on that and
well it remains to be seen if Hollywood
will be able to institute any kind of
culture of accountability I'm not very
hopeful for it but excellent excellent
analysis Perez thank you for being on
we've got to bring you back you you're
like the expert on all of these issues
thank you all right thanks about we'll
talk to you soon
all right now we have got to get to the
ugly people we were talking about how DC
is just Hollywood for ugly people now
let's get to the ugly people Senator
Jeff Flake will not be seeking
re-election
here is his grandstanding conscious of a
conservative speech the principles that
underlie our politics the values of our
founding are too vital to our identity
and to our survival to allow them to be
compromised by the requirements of
politics because politics can make us
silent when we should speak and silence
can equal complicity I have children and
grandchildren to answer to and so mr.
president I will not be complicit or
silent it is also clear to me for the
moment that we have given in or
government given up on the core
principles in favor of a more viscerally
satisfied anger and resentment but anger
and resentment are not a governing
philosophy let's be perfectly clear Jeff
Flake is not seeking re-election because
he would lose he's that's it he's played
along with various aspects of the
Republican Party and conservatism he's
played along with Trump he's pilloried
Trump the same thing with george w bush
but the reason that he's not seeking
re-election is not some grand moral
gesture it's because he knows he's going
to lose
same thing with bob Corker these are two
guys who have been very critical of
Trump but perhaps recklessly critical of
Trump and they've been a little squishy
on their votes they're not total
liberals some conservatives have said
they're far lefties or something they're
not they're they're just a little
squishy
nevertheless CNN is now reporting quote
any other president would be facing an
existential crisis after being accused
by two pillars of his own party of
debasing the nation they are they are
not pillars of the party I do I don't
CNN just might not know that because CNN
is fake news obviously as that that
video that we released the other day
shows you so they are not pillars of the
party they're trying to make a mountain
out of a molehill but certainly they
can't Matt Latimer former aide to Mitch
McConnell yes that Mitch McConnell the
squishy establishment Republican a
Senate Majority Leader said quote the
traditional Republican Party has to
decide if they're going to acquiesce to
trumpism or to rebel against it right
now the majority of the base seems to be
in favor of acquiescing there are a very
few willing to revolt
right now what what are you talking
about one must know what part of the
party you come from this is an aide to
Mitch McConnell what is the revolt the
Republican establishment has been giving
Donald Trump grief for it and in many
ways hysterical group in some ways
deserved grief but in some ways
utterly ridiculous grief since he opened
his mouth so you know whereas the
reverie one has revolted against him
Trump has managed to outmaneuver all of
them and two pretty good effect by the
way we've gotten good stuff out of
Donald Trump so far massive deregulation
matchy ditional nominees and an
originalist Supreme Court justice and a
shift in the culture we're no longer
talking about transgender bathrooms
we're talking about jobs and on those
cultural issues he's been willing to
wage a great cultural battle he's said
we need to respect our flag I'm not
saying we're gonna outlaw disrespecting
the flag but we should do it this is
something we haven't heard in a long
time people who have led the
conservative movement for a long time
Brent Bozell a media Research Center has
come out have come out strongly against
him Bozell said quote flake can blame
Trump all day long the truth is his
voters wanted him out he was a disgrace
conservative review gives him an F
rating on Liberty Bozell went on quote
flake was our number one target in 2018
for america's arizona member
that's his organization 148,000
conservative boots on the ground were
primed and ready to defeat him
obviously they he got that F rating from
conservative review Heritage action gave
him only a 67 percent we should be a
little fair to flake he's very weak on
immigration that's what accounts for
most of those low scores
he's got top scores on right to life an
NRA but you should consider the context
of flakes going rogue he waited to go
rogue until he knew he couldn't win he
the last time he went rogue was 2006 and
he lambasted his party that was right
before the Democrats swept the country
and it's right when Republicans were in
a really vulnerable and low point and he
jumped ship and started criticizing them
- corker bob corker also has a bit
squishy he didn't want to repeal certain
Obamacare taxes heritage action only
gives him a 50% score Club for Growth
only gives him an 80% score I know 80%
sounds high but Republicans need to be
pro-growth you shouldn't be that low
conservative review gives corker of 47%
the issue here I don't think is the vote
you're Pro immigration you're
anti-immigration it's the opportunism
it's in you know in flakes case seeming
like you're trying to save your own skin
rather than do the adult thing and risk
your political reputation risk looking
at yourself in the mirror to affect good
outcomes for the country
here is soon-to-be-ex senator bob Corker
discussing trump and among the comments
you made is that your concern his
comment the president's comments could
put us on the path to World War 3 yeah
and let me put it bluntly left to his
own devices do you think the president
is a threat to national security
I think that there are people around him
that work in an effort to contain him
that would be secretary Madison
Tillerson and general Kelly there his
chief of staff well that almost seems to
accept the premise of the question if he
needs to be contained I do think when
you have the kind of issue we're dealing
with in North Korea where we have a very
unstable leader there when you send out
tweets into the region to raise tensions
when you kneecap which is what he's done
publicly when you kneecap your Secretary
of State whose diplomacy you have to
depend upon to really bring China to the
table to do the things that need to be
done back-channeling in some cases to
North Korea when you kneecap that effort
so you really move our country into a
binary choice which could lead to a
world wars outrageous condescension from
bob Corker that's his answer he goes on
NBC News which is a communications wing
of the Democratic Party and he says yeah
I'll tell you folks I think that Donald
Trump he's gonna get us into World War 3
but he says it nice and slow and he's
nice and genteel and political and he's
so isn't he so polite and he's accusing
the president of getting us into World
War 3 when by all accounts Donald
Trump's policy on North Korea is better
than any of his predecessors let's not
forget here's a little quick history
lesson
Bill Clinton allowed the Kim regime to
get nuclear weapons george w bush was
fighting another war so he couldn't
focus on that and barack obama used a
strategy called strategic patience that
got us absolutely nothing so donald
trump by all accounts has handled this
well but there's bob Corker undercutting
his own president president from his own
party saying well we have the adults
there to babysit Donald Trump in the
White House absolutely despicable and
there's that there's that loyalty
question you know that we've heard for a
long time from Trump critics that Donald
Trump he's gonna move the country to
left he's gonna move the party left he's
gonna get rid of the conservatives he's
gonna sidle up to Democrats
fundamentally change the conservative
movement it's not what I'm seeing I'm
not seeing conservatives being primary
doubt I'm seeing squishy Republicans
being primary doubt and I'm seeing more
conservative challengers coming in
and in trying to take their spots so I
think that narrative is just falling
apart and let's not forget this other
thing politics is a team sport and you
can showboat and you can go around and
say look look at me I'm Jeff Flake and
all of you who are willing to actually
accomplish any political good for the
country
you guys are sellouts and you're immoral
and it's awful what you're doing well
look pal what have you done for us what
is all of your showboat in getting us
perhaps it makes you feel better about
yourself it makes you feel morally
superior but in the meanwhile the adults
are going to go out and actually
accomplish conservative and Liberty
focused policy objectives for the
country if it hints at what one thing I
really don't like which is I'm a
Republican but not that kind of
Republican you hear this a lot from
college kids I see it all the time well
I'm a conservative but I'm not one of
those conservatives I don't support this
I don't support that I don't please in
new york times please like me o
washington PLO's please give me give me
approval and that it's something we
should avoid
who cares what those people think you
got to you got to stick by your guys if
if by the way Donald Trump did something
egregious and you wanted to stand up to
him and say this is moving the party in
the wrong direction we shouldn't do it
be my guest
there could be some courage there but to
try to undercut him on petty things like
tweets or on his lack of couthe his
general impoliteness let's say that is
really despicable and you're putting
your own image in your own public image
above the good of the country because
again if bob Corker is suggesting the
trump's handling of north korea is is
awful for the country we need to move
away from it look at the results that
he's had he got that American student
released he's he's the first one to
really take a hard line with North Korea
and apparently show some strength after
three different presidents of both
parties have basically ignored the issue
so come on guys don't be a Republican
not that kind of Republican stick by
your guy eff eff is for flake I'm I'm
glad to see this movement in the party
and in the country but we're gonna have
to bring on our panel to see if
everybody agrees on that and before we
bring on our panel we've got to thank
our
we've got to thank the I can't believe
I'm shocked as anybody I know Marshall
shocked that someone is paying to keep
this show on but the lights are on the
cafe is in the mug and that is in part
thanks to stamps calm stamps calm is a
really great company it's a really good
business solution too because these days
you can get anything you want on demand
I'm a millennial I refused I fused to my
chair obviously I don't get out for
anything I make people feed me grapes by
the vines you don't have to go to the
post office you don't have to wait in
line anything that you can do at the
post office you can do from stamps.com
you can do it right from your desk you
can bind print official US postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer and your own printer it never
closes me I like to put things off I'm
obviously writing my show three seconds
before the on-air light goes on and I
never get to stores on time the post
office closes stamps calm is open 24/7
right now if you use my code and my code
for stamps calm is of course coffe FA
that's CoV f e f e you'll get a special
offer you get a four week trial that
includes postage and a digital scale why
would you ever turn that down you gotta
go there right now really just for the
novelty of typing stamps comm / cuff fa
c OV e fe fe do not wait before you do
anything else when you get to stamps
comm tap the microphone oh I'm sorry you
have to tap the microphone so it stamps
comm type in the code co f f/a
that's how they'll know that we sent you
and you'll you will never go to the post
office again alright let's bring on our
panel we have a very good panel today we
have from stanford ariel davidson we
have from the blaze conservative
millennial Allie's Stuckey and we have
from The Daily wire Emily Butler ladies
thank you for being here
first question I'll just go I'll do a
little round robin here starting with
Ally
are we happy that flake and corker are
gone is this a good thing for the
country in the party yeah absolutely and
it's a very easy card for them to play
the scapegoat card in which they say
they're laying down their political
careers for the advancement of some kind
of conservative principles I think we
know like you noted that sleep does
match
represent anymore very conservative
principles he ran as a Republican and
has actually ruled as a rhino he has
betrayed his constituents when it comes
to immigration and health care and now
he's trying to say that no fault of his
own he is uh leaving his long tenure as
a congressman and it's just not true
Jeff Lee gets on the popular because he
is an unpopular senator has nothing to
do with house couldn't agree more
aerial what do you think I agree with
allying and I'm gonna [ __ ] me out by
saying I think there's this weird
propensity within the Republican Party
especially to scapegoat Trump's tweets
um you know we can agree or disagree
about the content of Trance treaty and
what he chooses to talk about and the
way he does it is you need sometimes
think they're inappropriate but that's
you know that's his own essence own
decision that aside I think far too
often we see various members of Congress
and look at what Trump tweeted and I say
to myself no I'm more worried about what
you're performing and what you're doing
in Congress which at this point is
completely lame duck so I think it's
become a convenient scapegoat for
failing members of Congress such as
Lincoln Corcoran to turn to sort of
Trump's tweets and something that they
can fall on and you know earn them
accolades on Good Morning America and
they conduct interviews actually you
know I'm worried about your content
mm-hmm and what you're producing as a
member of Congress it's a little it's a
like magicians do they hold their
fingers over here they say oh look at
the tweets look at the tweets don't look
at my record just look at the tweets
it's a distraction it's ridiculous maybe
we waited seven years for repeal of
Obamacare and now we have four firms
leaked discussing how the pump isn't
appropriate I think you know there are
there are times and places and when we
can criticize the president but your
performance in Congress as you own no
place for everything in that place is
College you know quite frankly we can
talk about the Iran deal Emily what do
you think is this a good thing and is
this about political positions I think
it's more about branding than it has
anything to do with political positions
like like Ali and Ariel just said it's
something to do with your own person
brand and clearly corkers and flakes
brands are not doing well so this is
kind of a last-ditch effort to run in
and save that brand and you know
solidify that brand as one of those
people against Donald Trump that being
said I also think that there is like a
smaller and smaller percentage of people
who were part of the never Trump crowd
who are still against Trump and I think
personally Trump's brand of
conservativism conservatism works for
now I think Trump is the president we
need now I don't know if he is the
president who's going to do the best
justice for the Republican Party in the
long term so I don't necessarily have a
problem with fellow Republicans calling
him out or attacking him on certain
things I think that it gives President
Trump an opportunity to respond in a
more mature manner especially I think
every single attack on Trump gives him
an opportunity to build his brand better
or build his brand in a different way so
yeah of course
and that president Fernau is a good
point because I think some people who
are ideologue especially on the left but
there are some idiot logs on the right
too they say well it this everything
needs to be Abraham Lincoln basically
everything needs to be an eternal
principle but that isn't how politics
really works in real politics you have
particular people doing particular
things in a particular time in place and
so yeah you might not need your plumber
to live in your house with you but
sometimes you need the plumber to come
over and fix the drain Ali do you think
that loyalty should be a real
consideration in politics I know a lot
of people they want to say well you know
Trump is okay on this he's bad on this
and but he's not my guy he's just gonna
like him what I like him and I won't
like him when I won't like him is there
some team loyalty here some partisan
loyalty that we should give to Trump
that we should possibly give principle
is much more important than loyalty to
party and certainly more than loyalty to
any politician because if you have a
politician that challenges war
priorities
your principles they you know
countryside we shouldn't side make that
politician politicians change in fade
you've seen that you know several times
over the course of our industry but your
principles essentially shouldn't what I
do I don't think it's absolutely absurd
for president Trump to act for some sort
of loyalty and for him to appreciate
some sort of loyalty he's a businessman
that's kind of how he has run his life
and has run who several successful
businesses I don't think that that
salutely absurd and I also think it's
human nature I think anyone whether it
politics are not appreciate some sense
of loyalty I do what I don't really like
I don't mind the criticizing of Trump
like any politician I think there's a
way to do it peacefully and a way to do
it in a way that it's not necessarily
capitalizing upon this anti Trump
resistance but when you see people like
Corcoran see people like flake
blatantly telling lies and like we've
said before athlete is see folks not
taking responsibility for their own
actions and blame on Trump that's where
we have a problem
it's no longer honest criticism it is a
inabilities responsibility for their own
actions or inaction and that's right and
there's a great distinction you just
made between criticizing Trump or being
being loyal to your principles and being
loyal to the people obviously put not
your faith in Princes but I don't think
the criticism of Trump is about
principles I think the criticism of
Trump is because he's uncouth and it
isn't really nice to be associated with
him when you're in polite rarefied elite
company and so I think these guys are
criticizing him over tweets and and that
I don't think there's any reason to be
doing that I think it's disloyal
counterproductive it puts your own
polished image above the good of the
country
sure if Donald Trump suddenly wants to
raise taxes and says that we need to
have an annual or a nightly burning of
the American flag at every home in the
country yeah okay maybe we should we
should disagree with him in criticizing
their but they only but we have
for example Sachs is criticized
President Trump on threatening to revoke
the licenses whatever that means that
means anything and so there aren't some
matters of principle that I think some
conservatives are calling him out on and
I don't think that we can fair enough I
do think if he were to actually revoke
NBC's license that might be a problem
but Scott Adams had a great article in
The Wall Street Journal the other day
about how what Trump does what he's
doing when he's tweeting these sort of
things is he's getting you to go so far
that you're already accepting his
premises so when he's saying maybe we
should repeal NBC's licenses what he's
really doing is getting you to accept
the premise that NBC is corrupt and a
hack for Democrats and babies and so I
don't know I mean I maybe it goes a
little too far maybe Scott protests too
much but I'm really compelled by his
theory and yeah if Donald Trump starts
shutting down press offices I think it
might be fair enough to criticize him
okay I want to keep talking with my
excellent and beautiful and lovely
all-female panel of deplorable --zz I
want you to watch it too but you can't
watch the rest of it unless you go over
to Daily wire calm I want to thank
everybody who subscribes already it
keeps all of my my excellent panel
filled my cafe tears tumblr and left us
tears tumblr filled to the brim and the
lights on in our studios if you haven't
subscribed go to daily wire.com right
now it is $10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me I'll get the under
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
blah blah blah here it is this is what
you get the leftist here's tumblr what's
it made of today Michael this is made of
this is made of a metal so strong so
powerful that scientists are afraid to
even utter its name for fear of its of
its strength and Majesty go to the Daily
wire calm right now you get the leftist
here's tumblr we've got a lot of
excellent vintage is pouring out daily
we're calm we'll be right back
[Music]
I'm taking the glasses off I'm gonna get
a little more comfortable for this
members only part of the show we need to
talk about actress Heather Lind actress
Heather Lynne never heard of her I
hadn't either but she is now accusing 93
year-old wheelchair-bound vascular
parkinsonism suffering former Republican
President George Bush of sexually
assaulting her because he allegedly got
a little handsy and told her a joke
during a photo op the to put this in
context the pinned tweet on her profile
compares auntie fuh to u.s. soldiers
landing at Normandy
so that gives you a little idea for
ideological background Arielle has this
woman no shame you know I think that one
thing that struck me is first of all
President George HW Bush is in the
wheelchair so just from up here you're
positioning standpoint in the picture I
can imagine he might be in an
uncomfortable spot to begin with um I
know sometimes when I think of you know
gentlemen who are 70 years and older
sometimes they make jokes to connect
with younger people and it's a little
uncomfortable at times because your
sense of humor might just be different
um you know I'm not trying to minimize
any trauma might have experienced I
think it's a stretch I'm sure it was
real traumatic I'm sure I can imagine
it's a complete sexual assault and I
think it also denigrates real you know
situations that have been discussed
under the me to do ashtag situations
which women you know we're violently
taken advantage of and taking advantage
of a completely inappropriate context
and then you have this woman thing oh
you know I had an inappropriate joke
told and and there might have been some
uncomfortable touching during a picture
quickly and I'm thinking this really
sort of subtracts from you know the
message that there are women actually
out there who are using this platform to
discuss horrific assaults that have
taken place I mean the piece the other
day that it really it disrespects the
victims of the real assaults I think
that whole me to hash tag Emily what do
you think about this the you know this
is not a terribly prominent actress she
doesn't have a lot of Twitter follower
I learned when I went and looked over
today is this evidence as Ariel suggests
that me too is a navel-gazing enterprise
that isn't terribly concerned with
actual victims of sexual assault and
rape well you know I think the hashtag
me too was probably started in good
conscience trying to rally women
together to I almost said that you know
create a culture that it's okay to speak
out it's okay to say that this isn't
okay this behavior is not okay and I do
think that that goes even beyond rape
like I think that there are
inappropriate ways that men talk to
women or jokes that men think are funny
that maybe are not funny
I think the staggering you know just
absolute like ability to put it on
Instagram like not you're not making an
official complaint you're not like
making an allegation you're not and
asking for like an arrest you're just
asking for attention and this this
staggering like what is the word I'm
conceit of the the person who's claiming
to be a victim here is really just
seeking for this attention when all of
these other victims need some kind of
like I do I do want to say like I think
that this this is an exact example of
how this hashtag goes wrong basically I
think they know go ahead Arielle no you
go in an alley oh go ahead
you go ahead Marshall I actually do one
here from Ally on this alley do you
think that I don't want to be considered
insensitive here and I forget the author
but there was an excellent writer out of
Heritage Foundation who wrote a piece
saying I was roofied by a stranger I'm a
conservative her name is escaping me in
a moment it was a really good piece
basically giving the other side of this
argument does does me - does it
trivialize rape does this woman accusing
a man who can't move
of sexually assaulting her does that
trivialize rape or is it an important
conversation that we ought to be having
salt actually encompasses more than just
rape something that you said this guide
and Ariel mentioned this too so just
logistically I mean he was 90 years old
when this happened this was three years
ago he was nine years old a potato
probably 30 minutes to even reach for
this girl mystery that I want to solve
is she just letting this happen
and the article doesn't specify that he
actually certain we read appropriately
does he touched her from behind which is
kind of typical in pictures so for all
you know he could have touched her ankle
he could have touched her up her back
and yeah he's a real ball like ariel
says he might have told an offeror joke
but the fact that she is jumping on this
trend this is what happened hearing
bandwagon syndrome and when sexual
assault becomes trendy me tried to go
back in the recesses of our mind and
scour our memories to try to find
something that maybe relates to this
hashtag so we can jump on it too and
that's exactly what she gave and you
know what she was embarrassed after she
did it she knew she trivialized intended
actual sexual assault because she took
it in Terrell and she should have it
embarrassing and the 90 year old man
touch you maybe someone inappropriately
maybe made a funny joke his mic rolled
his eyes and now three years later
you're so disturbed by it that when
teamily you were just going to release
this harrowing tale at the same time
that a hashtag is ready Wow and you and
that's a great observation
she never actress actually says that he
touched her too cos that's what I
assumed she meant when she said he
touched me from behind right but she
never said that that's true he could
have could have touched wherever and
made an awkward joke and now it's a
federal case now this story that all
right we'll move off of President Bush
and that took us touching and all of
that this story is genuinely shocking
the Washington Post broke an actual news
story that could be we could talk about
that in and of itself but maybe
we'll get into the actual story they
broke the Washington Post broke the
story on Tuesday night that the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the Democrat
National Committee helped pay for the
now-famous dossier of research on
President Trump you know with the
hookers and the bodily fluids flying
everywhere that dossier was paid for by
Democrats and now fusion GPS is the
organization that's at the center of all
this it's a research firm that hired
Christopher Steele a former British
intelligence agent who was versed in
Russia related issues this means that
Democrats paid a foreigner to interfere
in the election which is irony that
transcends parity they have been
accusing Donald Trump of doing this for
11 months
turns out we now have hard evidence that
they did it also fusion has ties to the
Kremlin
so fusion GPS the firm that they
enlisted has ties to Vladimir Putin it
even worked with the Russian lawyers who
were present during that big Donald
Trump jr. meeting that they're trying to
hype up and make a big deal over the
Democrats have not acknowledged any of
this but even their communications from
the Washington Post had to admit it in
this story
Ariel our Democrats going to be sorry
that they called for this special
counsel to analyze foreign interference
in the election I think they will be the
one thing I wanted to ask you is that
one of the favorite my favorite parts
about the DNC releasing a statement
we've got their current leadership had
no involvement I'm like okay great
I can't even from at a top threads and
keith Ellison put into power within the
last year so that's not a very large
time frame but a great they aren't
responsible that's what truck me is sort
of fascinating and I think you know we
go back through Donald Trump's tweets
going back to his tweets he actually had
a tweet of Steve needs ago before all
this release saying you know I wonder
who paid for the dossier was it the FBI
was it the entry was it the Clintons and
you should see all the responses people
singing shut up you're wrong all of this
stuff and so I took actually sweet
satisfaction from realizing that you
know Donald Trump was actually correct
this was this
I have it and this entire affair stinks
to high heaven and this is one of the
few times that I would like to see more
media personalities saying know what
Trump was actually correct you um and
you know this is one of those times
where I don't think it's really getting
much credit for that know what they're
going to say Arielle they're they're
always gonna say well he accidentally he
got he was right well it was a yeah I
guess coincidentally he was right but
you know he wasn't supposed to be right
and we don't want him to be right so I
don't want to admit it but you know the
guys been coincidentally write a lot
consistently yeah so I you know I will
regret this as you suggested and I think
we'll start to see this goes a lot
deeper than we initially anticipated um
and all the rhetoric they put about out
there about Harold trunk was influence
an election and hiring no foreign agents
to do so to have this back in their face
um it's disturbing but it's also you
know for all the rhetoric they put up
with kind of deserve it at this point
mm-hm the as you bring up to Trump
called this a while ago
the fusion GPS story has been popped up
months ago a buddy of mine who works in
a completely unrelated industry I think
he sent me an email about this on July
27th or something in late July is saying
hey what's up with fusion GPS Emily why
are the media only picking up on it now
you mean you're asking me why the media
dragged its feet in vindicating
President Donald Trump yeah I just I've
been scratching my head you know I know
it's a question I'm trying to figure out
too
but um like why do fish swim you know
like why does the Sun Shine I don't yeah
I think it's the gills I'm not I'm not
too sure how that works well obviously I
mean I don't think the meeting even if
they have the resources to go in and do
investigative reporting and figure out
actually the truth they're not going to
send those resources out to the opposite
party out to the political enemy and
they want to do everything they can to
cover up - silence - you know prop up
the DNC to prop up the Clintons this is
you know right during all of what
happened well what did happen Hillary
what happened what happened here what
happened in the Clinton campaign like
what
whatever happened immediate never
gonna ask those questions they're gonna
ask Hillary how she feels how she feels
about losing how she feels about
everything how she feels about well you
know not about being married to Bill
Clinton or a rapist but you know those
are those are questions that the media
just does not have you're talking about
my cousin now thank you very much now if
I grab Harley's Ally president Trump
said on this Russia issue quote now it's
turning out that the hoax is turned
around is that right is this whole
Russian narrative just being flipped on
its head
well I certainly hope so that would be a
great Halloween surprise for Republican
certainly I don't know if it's being
necessarily turned around completely I
do think that we are going to see
Democrats swept up in it and like you
said they're probably going to regret
appointing a special counsel but for
those of us who actually care about
seeing the truth whether it's one side
or the other I think this is great even
if people from both sides of the aisle
are kind of unfortunately involved in
this whole collusion scandal or if no
one it I'm just ready to see the truth I
think most American people are ready to
see the truth actually we want to know
what's real versus what's narrative so
we're gonna have people now on both
sides of the aisle um ready to see the
conclusion I want the truth I can't
handle the truth I can't take any more
there have just been too many truth
bombs today I wanted to talk about the
Las Vegas shooter
the shooters brothers weird kiddie porn
fascination and why he's been arrested
but we don't have time that's all right
we'll save the kiddie porn for next time
that is our show panel thank you for
being here and all blonde all female all
expert panel of deplorable z-- Allie
Stuckey Emily Butler and Arielle
Davidson I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show come back tomorrow
get your mailbag questions in now so
that I can change your life for the
better and we'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]